[Music]
China has named a new foreign minister
reappointing Wang Yi to replace Jin Khan
gang had not been seen in public since
the end of June sparking speculation
about his health and whereabouts he
previously served as foreign minister
between 2018 and 2023. the governor of
China's Central Bank has also been
replaced Katrina Yu is in Beijing so
Katrina what happened I mean first the
foreign minister just drops off the
radar nobody knows where he is for a
month and then mysteriously we find out
he's been replaced
that's right speculation had been
mounting qingang had not been seen for
at least four weeks at a time of intense
diplomatic activity for China he was
last seen in public meeting with
Vietnam's foreign minister in June but
since then he had missed a number of
high-level visits by U.S officials at a
time when Beijing is trying to stabilize
ties with Washington he also missed
earlier this month and Asian Foreign
ministers meeting and the reason given
for him not to participating at the time
was ill health now this decision and our
announcement of Qing gong's removal was
given after a meeting by China's
national peoples Congress standing
committee on Tuesday it was decided that
he would be replaced by actually his
predecessor Wang e now this is an
enormous shock qingdong's rise in the
Communist Party had been rapid and
meteoric at the age of 57 he was one of
the youngest officials ever to be named
foreign minister of post he only held by
the way for seven months he was named
from Mr in December and before that he
was China's ambassador to the United
States for two years and previously he
was a foreign Ministry spokesperson and
actually one of the original so-called
wolf Warriors known for his very
assertive diplomatic style and another
reason this is such a shock is that
qingdong was known for being a close and
trusted Ally of President Xi Jinping and
this closeness was really seen to have
boosted his career qingang managed to
achieve in years what would have taken
other officials decades now we don't
know any uh exact reason for his removal
but I do have to mention that while Qing
gun has been removed from this post as
foreign minister he still retains
another Communist party title of State
councilor which is arguably more senior
so this is leading analyst to say it
could be that he hasn't fallen
completely out of favor and it could be
that there is something else to this
right so speculation as always we'll
have a guest on in a moment but first
though tell us more about Wang Yi the
the new foreign minister who is
reprising his role as foreign minister
um just until now he was the country's
top diplomat
that's right so wangi is still the
country's top Diplomat so his official
role is Foreign Affairs office director
and he outranked qingang so he will
retain that role alongside also having
the role as foreign minister a role to
which he had previously for 10 years so
this dual role situation for one year
that's a lot on his plate and it's
leading many to believe that this
situation could be temporary uh and in
due course there will be another foreign
minister named but of course one year's
experience as foreigners he held that
post for 10 years before he was taken
over by Qin gong he will be a familiar
face and I think it's very much hope
that Beijing will have wangi in their
Corner as a stabilizing Force at a time
which is really marked by a lot of
upheaval for the foreign minister at the
moment so continuity at the top of
China's diplomacy Katrina you in Beijing
thank you very much let me turn to
Nicholas beckerlin he is a senior fellow
at Yale University's China Center you're
doing is from New Haven in Connecticut
about this do you think we'll ever know
what happened to uh Jin gang
I think we may know but
um we don't know for for the moment and
I think this is very reflective of the
way that the Communist Party functions
especially at the highest level uh
disappearances are not uncommon they're
actually the rule when you have a
problem with a top official whether it's
factional struggling or corruption or
just a health matter
um the party really doesn't think about
the public the public comes last on the
list of things to say this is the party
who decides when and what it tells the
public first it has to solve the problem
internally but this is a huge
embarrassment for China I mean qingang
the foreign minister is the public face
of China with the world on the
international stage and it's hard to
overstate the impact that negative
impact that this is having among
diplomats around the world
to the point you were just messing about
this making about how this is China how
China operates here's a list of people
who went missing in the past decade it's
not the exhaustive full list tennis
player Peng shui artist way way
celebrity actress Yahweh Interpol Chief
Meng hongwei business Mogul Jack ma now
the foreign minister now for quite a few
of those they at some point re-emerged a
few weeks or a few months after they
dropped off the radar but not all
um
if this does not seem to actually
disrupt the way the Chinese government
functions it doesn't look like this is
disrupting Chinese diplomacy
question of Chinese diplomacy
um depends on one man XI tingping
himself is made of very clear uh imprint
on crime policy it's turned the page of
China playing sort of a key a low-key
role in the world it has stated China's
ambition to be a peacemaker in Ukraine
in Yemen
between Saudi Arabia and Iran I mean he
is really the one who drives uh the
direction of foreign policy and then as
your correspondent in Beijing was saying
we have one year who outranks qingang is
a member of the Central Committee is a
former foreign minister so he's the one
really implementing the strategy qingang
as the foreign minister is the one who
sort of runs the day-to-day Machinery
but that is nonetheless very important
because diplomats relies on their rely
on trust they rely on knowing each other
they're relying on the ability to which
to each other it's highly concerning
when you have the fine Minister just
disappearing for amounts without but
Nicholas a proper explanation foreign
diplomats no Wang Yi I mean the the
Spate of uh high-level American either
diplomats or just uh leaders of
government that that were in Beijing
recently they all met in addition to the
foreign minister in fact often before
meeting the foreign minister they were
weeding they were meeting Wang Yi so
it's not gonna be much of a difference
to them
well it does actually because yes uh
China's foreign diplomacy doesn't
disappear from one day to the next but
how can you count on building something
on finding Solutions on assigning
agreements when the foreign minister
just disappear for weeks China is a
highly hierarchical bureaucracy if the
top guy at the foreign Ministry is not
there it completely paralyzes within the
system and for foreign diplomats
especially in Asia when Qing gong missed
the very critical asean meeting which
southeast Asia is really the the sort of
the front line of the battle of
influence between China and the us at
the moment this is really a big Miss for
China and it puts back in the mind of
people that China is unpredictable that
at any point people can disappear that
you have no guarantee that what comes uh
on the next day and I think that is the
reminder that China is trying to avoid
as it casts itself as a sort of a very
stable
trustworthy and reliable architecture of
a new world order that is supposed to
come after the american-led one all
right Nicholas Beckel and Senior fellow
at Yale University's China Center thank
you very much we'll be keeping an eye
out to see whether qingang re-emerges
and if so what he might have to say
thank you very much
thank you